joining me now is the presenter and
hydrogen
car owner james may james good to talk
to you
i know that you're a man who likes his
motors so my first question to you
really
is how is the ride different um well i
i should come clean as uh have a
hydrogen electric car and the battery
electric car because i'm
uh comparing them in the real world and
i'm trying to take part in the
experiments i'm not an evangelist for
either i'm keeping an open mind
but in both cases because they're both
essentially electric cars the experience
is
uh quiet serene and
uh polite is the word i often use
because i can drive them very early in
the morning which i often do and i don't
wake people up so i'm a big fan of
electric motoring but i think
uh both both solutions hydrogen and
batteries
are fraught with potential problems the
problem for batteries is
the mining of the difficult materials
and very unclean mining
the fact that they're still taking a
long time to charge and there's no
obvious battery development on the
near horizon um the problem with the
hydrogen car is it refills quickly but
it's very difficult to find the hydrogen
it's very difficult and expensive
to produce clean hydrogen most of it at
the moment is is gray hydrogen made by
reforming fossil fuels
um as you say if we use it with
sustainable energy it will become
perfectly clean but
it's also not very energy efficient but
then maybe that doesn't matter it's it's
a massively complicated subject
batteries are unsuitable for things like
aeroplanes because the batteries we have
would be enormous and unworkable so
i think there's actually room for
battery and hydrogen cars in the future
battery cars are great if you can charge
at home if you're not a massive user you
know we know the statistics most people
only drive
short distances eight miles a day and
they can recharge overnight if they have
somewhere to do it
the advantage of the hydrogen car is is
more that it's not a solution for the
car
it's the car take on a bigger energy
picture which is a hydrogen
infrastructure and a hydrogen economy so
it would really be put in place for
things like ships aviation heavy haulage
and the car would benefit from it the
car as it is benefits massively from the
battery revolution but it doesn't
transfer so well to things like haulage
shipping and aviation
this is why i think we'll end up with
both and maybe some other things besides
james you described it as a polite drive
now you're a man who likes
i think the thrill of a drive is the
most exhilarating thing
about driving a hydrogen car is not
knowing when perhaps you're going to
find the next hydrogen filling station
well i yes i do get a perverse thrill
out of that because there's a bit of
brinksmanship
involved um and i yeah i do i do enjoy
it i
i have a very good mental picture now of
where the hydrogen filling stations are
i am in london so i'm in
a lucky position i've got two within a
few miles of my house
and on regular journeys i make i know
how far i can go before i'm out of range
of the hydrogen filler there's nothing
you can do if you run out
if you run out in a battery car you can
push it to a plug and you can plug it in
anyway you can't do that with hydrogen
so yes i do enjoy that um
my new hydrogen i've just got the new
toyota um it's got a bigger tank and a
bigger range and it's a bit more
efficient and i find i'm a little bit
more relaxed about using it but there
are still parts of the country where
if i'm going there in all honesty i have
to take the ferrari it's as simple as
that
you poor man my heart goes out to you
and 2030 there's going to be a ban
on sales of petrol and diesel cars do
you think we'll be ready and will
hydrogen
be a part of that mix um i hope hydrogen
will be a part of that mix
certainly for those other areas i
mentioned like vans
big lorries and so on um i i think
i think we can be ready but i think some
of the challenges are bigger than people
are wanting to admit
so with everybody says there's only
eight and a half thousand or slightly
fewer than eight and a half thousand
petrol stations left in britain these
days the number has been declining since
the 60s
but what they're forgetting is most of
them have at least
five some of them have 20 pumps and
they're occupied for a few minutes at a
time
whereas battery cars even with really
good supercharging networks still take
tens of minutes sometimes an hour to
recharge so
even though we've got more charging
points than petrol stations
i don't think it's anything like enough
yet because if you multiply
the number of pumps at a petrol station
and then multiply that again by the
number of minutes you need to occupy an
electric charge you i worked out the
other day that the country needs
something like 1.2 million
so it's not going to be for everybody
and if you are
traveling the country selling
encyclopedias or any of those other
things that people drive around doing
then it's going to be tricky to use a
battery electric car and a hydrogen car
would be nicer if there were the filling
stations
i filled mine up two days ago and i
timed it out of interest which i do
fairly regularly because i'm that kind
of bloke and it took four minutes and 10
seconds
and that gave me a range of 300 miles
and that is glorious
really good to talk to you james may
thank you thank you